so i'm david christensen i advised by
market kowski here in stanford and i'm
here to talk to you about my research
microbots working in a macro world so
we're going to start with the motivation
of why we do any of these things and
then go through a lot of slides so for
starters here um basically when you look
at the world of microbots we can break
it down into about four categories give
or take so top left here we have robots
made for use within the body and this is
you can kind of think of it inspired by
bacteria or viruses some of them
explicitly are inspired by such things
but the main idea is when you're within
the human body size is inherently
important you need to be small otherwise
you're harming human and so that's a
huge motivation for some microbots often
you'll find that they have
infrastructure that's much larger than
themselves because that's okay to the
human can have electromagnet surround
them or things but but the actuators
themselves would be inside the human
body and so would want to be size
reduced there's some terrific work by
brad nelson there's a micro robot that
can swim within the ocular fluid of the
eye and then puncture veins and deliver
medicines there's another Mike robot
that he's developed that can be used
inside the heart to perform ablations
and all sorts of interesting things so
this is a whole category of robots we're
not going to talk about much today but
they're terrific um the next interesting
area that we kind of think about is ok
so we're outside of the human body well
why would we want a small robot I'm one
possibility is to be inspired by
cockroaches so you have rapid and robust
ground transport so cockroaches can get
darn near anywhere they can run really
fast they're really simple in the mind
but they have complex mechanics that
make them sort of inherently stable and
that's a really terrific inspiration for
roboticists so there's a whole bunch of
actually cockroach inspired robots
there's I sprawl there's Ron fairing
group has velocity and a lot of really
cool robots there and so this is a whole
category believe it not cockroach
microrobots it's a thing yeah that's
right so so the main thing there would
be mainly taking a sensor platform and
putting it somewhere else so mapping
exploring you're not delivering much
they don't carry much payload but they
can move quickly over sort of ambiguous
train so that's that's fantastic
the next sort of interesting area and
this is a new one not super new but in
the last couple years we're seeing bees
as sort of the inspiration for flying
micro robotics this is kind of similar
to cockroaches in that they're going to
move quickly they're going to move on
unstructured train because they just fly
over it they're not going to carry much
payload though they're flying and that
takes a lot of power and that's about
all they can do at this point you know
it'll get better but but really they're
going to be Power Limited an interesting
thing about bees themselves when they're
in their natural habitat they're going
from point A home to point B flowers
that want to be found so they have big
colorful indicators and they're pretty
obvious and so the binos I'm trying to
go from here to here and I don't really
care about much in between so I'm going
to go straight shot I'm going to do it
fast I'm not going to carry a lot with
me or back i'm just going to carry some
nectar back and sort of that's the whole
scheme and so that's a fantastic thing
you know you can do mapping you can do
all sorts of things you could envision
bees doing with robots um so that's
really cool but inherent in their
physics your trading power for force and
so there's a couple integrals that are
not helping you there and you're not
going to be very good at carrying large
payloads because that's just not going
to work so they're fantastic but they're
not going to be able to affect the human
world in meaningful ways they're not
going to move anything on this desk for
instance and so we are specifically
interested in robots that do affect the
human world so not only go and take
sensor measurements from point A and
point B and then bring them back but
take sensor measurements record readings
make a logical decision on the fly and
decide to change the environment and
response so move a rock would be a
simple example something that's in the
way on one goal would be even discovered
that the door to your room was open and
close it you know sort of work in the
human scale world that's the goal so we
want to affect in Hue in scale world and
ants are an interesting way to sort of
be inspired there they have incredibly
strong ground motion and and that avoids
that integral that flying sort of has to
deal with the power vs force they trade
work for force instead so that's better
and they have really interesting team
behavior so there's a lot to study with
ants they're fantastic really
complicated species even though there's
they do a lot of really amazing things
so they're they're terrific and they'll
be our inspiration for this work we're
not the only ones there's some other
groups doing research more about the
behaviors there's other groups that are
also doing kind of different kind of
motions and things to mechanics so
there's your 20,000 foot overview of
microbots as broken into four quadrants
and it really does cover a lot of them
believe it or not so that's sort of
where we are and where we're going we're
trying to make micro robots that not
only measure things in the world but
affect the human scale of worlds in
response all right back to our outline
here so now we're going to talk about
ways that humans increase force so you
have a nail and you want to drive it in
if you stood on that nail you're
probably not gonna be able to drive it
and if you jumped you might have a
little bit better chance but how do we
drive in that nail well we use a hammer
and that's a clever trick it basically
is able to integrate motion over
distance put it into the velocity of a
mess and then trade that in a short time
duration to drive that nail in with an
astronomical force and so that's a
clever trick we use all the time even if
we don't think about it so that's that's
neat so using our own sort of intuition
it would be reasonable design
microrobots with this intuition and in
fact there are many so here's a sort of
very simple schematic of such a MicroBot
we have a magnet on a suspension the
magnet also has mass and then there's a
frame around there and then if we change
the magnetic field can't do that very
well if we change the magnetic field
like this that mass will resonate it'll
start to get a large amplitude and then
I'll start to hit on the ground and kind
of bounce and that's a way that these
things are able to move there will be
able to apply you know many times their
body weight as instantaneous forces they
strike and they're able to sort of move
smoothly that way despite kind of being
sticky when you get small so again we're
able to get a large force achieved by
changing that momentum quickly so so
that's certainly a way that humans do
interact with the world larger than
themselves so can we use this physics
now to pull a load so we have a proof
mass here and we have a little micro
robot and that Mike robot wants to now
drag this mass around
so that's the goal it's not chance the
one I drew there this is a toy available
it's called a hexbug nano here it is in
slow-motion so it just kind of hops
along the surface it generates upward
velocity and then as it hits the ground
it trades that downward velocity now for
our little spike in momentum and it gets
a little surge and then it's able to
take more force out of the system than
it could normally generate so that's a
pretty clever system I'm feel free to
interrupt at any point by the way if you
have any questions or anything so the
physical assumptions of the system
specifically are that on the average in
the long term this robot is going to be
limited by the mechanism proposing it so
if it's a friction based robot it's
going to have a long term time average
limit of its body weight x and g and mu
mg sorry but it is allowed to have
impulsive spikes that are above this in
the short term so specifically we're
talking about time average force that is
no greater than the static friction
affords it and the max change in
momentum in a stride is governed by
these simple equations but the main
point is TP is the period of the strides
that's the duration over which it's
going to take a step and it's
accumulating that velocity here we see
um basically it's taking out that
momentum in a short burst so TP was the
period of the stride TC is the contact
time of that force so if it's an
impulsive robot it's going to be small
it's going to accumulate that momentum
and then take it out in a small burst
and that gives you a force impact that's
basically the ratio of TP / t seen so
looking at that more geometrically just
first intuition here we have four
different robot gates we have robot D is
a smooth-running robot so it's maybe
walking or a driving car it's just kind
of smoothly moving on and it's applying
a force almost all the time so the
colored portion is the time that's of
buying the force and the white portion
is the time that it's sort of recovering
so that's you know a pretty smooth
moving robot um see might be a walking
robot now a little bit more jerky but
still pretty consistent be
we're starting to see you know most of
the time now it's not spending
reciprocal ittle bit of force a lot of
force in a short amount of time I'm
sorry and then a here is sort of the
limit and that's sort of like if you
took a hammer and you hit a string
you're going to increase your momentum
until you take it all out in this one
little burst so what would their ground
reaction forces look like um here we
have the long boring strike is
generating its worst almost the whole
time and then the shorter the time in
which we take the force out the larger
the force were able to get so that's
interesting but just comes from some
basic assumptions and physics and you
see there's different grf groups here so
again this is what these robots look
like just as a reminder so we have these
little hopping robots that sort of surge
against the little string on the back
side there and if we measure the force
in that string this is what we get we
would have a series of sparse but large
four spikes and that is able to exceed
the robot weight and also the level
predicted by just um gee so this is
successful this robot has achieved an
interaction force with the world larger
than a spotty weight and that's that's
doing great for it so that's terrific we
basically are seeing a boost in the peak
force capability of the robot in this
case it's about three body weights so
that's pretty good this is about four to
five times what the coefficient of
friction would predict so this is robots
punching above its weight and that's
fantastic so now we're going to look at
an example of how to use such systems to
actually interact with as part of the
human scale world so this is a excellent
little video that s RI let me show today
if you haven't seen their little micro
magnet robotic platforms they're pretty
neat basically it's magnets floating on
a circuit board that has locally
generated magnetic fields and they
follow those around so it's low-cost
they're able to move surprisingly
quickly they can even go up walls
because there's an attractive force they
can do interesting things like go on on
Evans and different planes you can use a
lot of them together basically the cost
was in developing the circuit board so
you can just add more magnets to add
more robots the robot itself is totally
passive that's right the board is not
and you know from a holistic view the
board is part of the robot but so here
we see two robots actually working
together this one is picking glue out of
a glue reservoir and placing it on a
substrate and then it flips and it's
going to pick in place a carbon rod into
that glue puddle and then they're going
to trade out and the other one is going
to do the same and they're kind of doing
teamwork here here's a robot picking and
placing a vertical rod into an actively
developing trust here's later research
you can tell the video qualities a
little better and they are doing a more
detailed build cycle of a real trust now
so you know kind of feet scale so
definitely human scale these robots
themselves or maybe about a centimeter
on a side give or take so they're pretty
small and don't weigh much at all
so here is the trusted building goes out
off the camera the truss is moved by
basically the equivalent of a crane so
something in the world is moving the
truss larger than the more robots can
move but then they assemble it the sort
of end is it sort of grows there using
an adhesive with ultraviolet here so
they can sort of cure on command there's
the structure I've seen it it's about
this long haven't held it because it
might break it precious research and
here we see it's it's quite strong so
that was a kilogram sitting on top of
this this is definitely a human scale
structure and it's being built by
microrobots so this is definitely our
goal and it looks like explaining again
sorry okay so so here we see the the
strength beats again we've got a one
kilogram weight on this little trust
that these not very heavy robots built
here's 200 grams in sort of a tricky
mechanical situation that really wants
to break at the base and it's not that's
great so this is really exciting stuff
but we have to ask the question these
robots are not actively powered so
they're not super intelligent we can add
intelligence in the system with cameras
or other sort of external sensors but we
want to be able to check their work
because presumably the goal here is to
build large structures with hundreds of
thousands of joints and if you just rely
on statistics to all be correct that's
not going to work so what if
hypothetically this joint right here was
not functional well this whole thing
would crumble and it'd be of mild
disaster so we here at Stanford sort of
weird developing quality control for
these robots now one of the tricks here
is these are human scale forces that
they're applying right I have a one
kilogram weight that this structure is
fine with and if I use these micro
robots that are able to apply sub gram
they can't really affect that much
they're so small compared to the
strength of the structure that they're
not going to be hugely appreciated the
microbots this one is I think three
millimeters on the sides are pretty tiny
and then this is one of the joints that
they built and basically the trick here
is to do's the momentum trick so we're
building up speed and then we crash into
the structure and that momentum is
transferred to the structure quickly
and that excites its resonant
frequencies and then using this
microphone that is very close to the
camera we can track those resonant
frequencies and actually tell how much
glue is in that joint to one part in 100
is pretty amazing sensitivity and that's
all thanks to this trick of trading
momentum for force so here we see this
is an important but we see on two
different resonant frequency sweeps one
without and one with the glue joint so
we're definitely seeing discerning that
capability and and that's great umm so
so trading momentum for force is great
let's go ahead and build a swarm right
now we're good to go um well there is a
problem with this whole scenario maybe a
couple but we're going to talk about one
today so here is an easy to grasp demo
if you don't mind bear with me here and
we'll just go through this so clapping
is the same as impulse right I'm going
to take my two hands i'm going to
accumulate velocity and then i'm going
to trade it out in out in an impact so
we're going to try to work as a micro
robot team today every one of us and
we're going to try out all clap at
exactly the same time exactly the same
time not close but exactly the same time
so on three we're going to all clap
ready 123 okay that was if you heard not
great you all did fine that's the
expected result but there's it's really
hard to get these impulsive loads to
happen at exactly the same time and that
was actually cheating you are actually
applying an internal force to the robot
and that's the easy thing it's the
external forces that are harder so we're
going to do this one more time and it'll
probably worse you're going to if you
have a neighbor gets your nearest
neighbor and do a joint high five we're
going to try to all high five at the
same time so you don't know where the
outside world is exactly but you're
taking take a best guess so spend five
seconds figure out a nearby neighbor got
your got your plans all right thank you
guys ok ready 1 2 3 all right so you
heard that that was a lot of disparate
spikes and they didn't overlap at all
and in fact I did this in lab this
morning so this is a lab study five of
my lab mates or six
five and I got together and we did some
claps so we all clapped individually and
you can see the the audio signal from
those cops someone was more aggressive
than others but this is the set and then
we all tried to do a clap at the same
time and here's the actual result it's
maybe twenty percent larger than the
biggest one but statistically not
different and you see that where these
are all sharp over here that kind of
builds and that's the the difference in
the clap so they're just not able to add
very well and the bottom line here is
one that you should understand by now
synchronization of impulse is hard it's
quite hard the more impulsive you are
the harder it is to synchronize so we're
going to come back to this concept later
but that's sort of why we're going to
need another concept so looking at that
um let's think about adhesive robots so
we asked how else can we generate large
forces well instead of using our
intuition with hammers let's think about
nature so here we have two examples of
animals that are known for their
strengths granted they're different
strings so we have an elephant and he's
pulling I think it's a cart full of
rocks or gravel over here on big forces
they can certainly not a problem to
apply big forces of the world and then
over here we have a leaf cutter ant cute
little pitcher but if we zoom out we
actually see that that leaf cutter ant
is easily being held by its buddy and
this is not even a problem for it at all
I don't think it even noticed so answer
pretty amazing granted they're smaller
than elephants they can't move an
elephant but their relative strength is
incredible so let's think carefully
about the elephant basically elephants
rely on friction and friction is great
lend your big when you're now isn't
that's fantastic and that's because um
the force you're able to generate the
friction force scales is el to the third
so if you want more friction force get
bigger simple become an elephant and you
got this covered um but if you wanted to
be small for some other reason if you
wanted to be a micro robot then this
clearly doesn't work just at all so
we'll come back to this in a second but
it's a simple scaling law we have an
aluminum cube with the rubber base as
the cube gets bigger the resistive force
to pull it goes up and here's just what
that trend looks like we're going to
come back
this in a second so now let's think
about the case of our friends the ends
well adhesion is what they use and
that's fantastic when you're small and
this is specifically because the force
of adhesion is proportional to the
contact area of it or l squared so as
you get smaller adhesion is going to be
the more useful force as it scales
decrease l squared is going to be more
helpful than L to the third so here
we're going to come back to that curve
again now we see our friction curve and
we say well let's put a dry silicone
adhesive on that same cube and just
compare the relative strengths of these
things so interesting point in this very
simple system it's a cube our crossover
point is that 100 inches so that says
that we should probably be thinking
about adhesives for anything that's even
moderately small that's quite a large
crossover point um and secondly in the
size range where we start to consider it
as micro robots which is ironically
about an inch cubed it's not micro
really but that's what we call it we see
there's a 100x difference in the forest
capability so adhesive is going to be
incredibly attractive in this kind of
size range okay so that brings us to the
next problem adhesion is great but if
you've ever played with duct tape before
you know it's slow you put it down on
the table and you have to work to get it
off and it's going to take effort um
hypothetically if you wanted to move
your car you could put duct tape on your
feet you'd get a little bit more grip
and that would be great but you never
run that way very well you hit and we
awkwardly stock and probably trip so
adhesion is sort of problematic because
it's usually slow this becomes even more
of a problem when you're a micro robot
if you're going to live in the human
scale world and your leg length is tiny
that implies that that leg needs to
recycle very quickly so you really need
to be even faster than we're used to and
so this is going to be a big problem
adhesives are generally slow if not even
permanent sometimes depending on your
force ability to remove them we would
note that rebuilds removability is a
minimum requirement for use in a mobile
robot
it's not very mobile so here we have a
chart we have on this axis force and we
have time scale over here and we see
that friction is low force relatively
speaking but is nice because it's
available all the time I suppose um but
can be turned off and on controllable
the relies on friction would be applying
an active clamp to the object then
removing that clamp over and over and
that can really be controllable so
that's going to be able to be more
useful on the other axis we have
adhesive tape is bonded so it's going to
have more strength available which is
great but then it's also kind of close
to permanence that's not fantastic so
what we really want here is a
combination of can be turned off and on
and has adhesive properties for strength
and we're going to call that
controllable adhesion so now let's look
in detail about controllable adhesion
before we start have any of you heard
about are controllable adhesives before
just out of curiosity or is this all
kind of new to everybody got one or two
little nods okay so those in the know
you're going to know what I'm talking
about here those who aren't that's great
we'll get through it I'm going to
introduce you right now to an incredibly
useful force from nature a force whose
magnitude scales with size it keeps
things stable and from slipping it can
be turned on and off simply by removing
the normal force I the normal ensure
that it generates are temporally synced
which is incredibly useful because this
enables dynamic motion like walking or
running also of use it can be reused
unlimited number of times them like that
permanent tape so that's fantastic those
in the know we're talking about control
of adhesion right actually this was just
friction and it's a really interesting
point that we don't think about friction
much because it just lives in our world
and we just rely on it I put all these
things here on my desk expecting them
not to very slowly slide off if the desk
wasn't super flat and it's just sort of
here and we don't even really think
about it but it's incredibly useful in
our lives we use it all the time so I
think you know this is a call out the
friction is fantastic and we should
consider its use more often but we're
not interested in friction today we're
interested in it he
so let's look at maybe an alternative so
here is an ant he's climbing up this
stock and you can barely see if you look
carefully there's a little bit of
discoloration at the feet and that's
because he's got an adhesive that's
grabbing on to the stock this would be
tricky with friction may be possible but
certainly tricky but this is interesting
because you know this ant has to move it
a quick step rate but yet is using
adhesion and that adhesion turns off and
on quickly and so here's how that
actually works apologies for the crude
diagram but it's the best I had um so
here's an ant leg right here and he has
a little hook on the end and he's
interacting with the world which you
know has some roughness perhaps or not
doesn't really matter a ton at that size
scale but basically as the ant pulls on
its leg so the body is back this way um
it's going to deform the hook and then
that's a mechanical object that it's
just a lever system basically that spits
out a little bit of adhesive and so as
that deformation continues that adhesive
is going to come out more and then find
the substrate and become stuck and now
the ants able to hang upside down
because it's got adhesive engaged um but
as soon as the ant goes the other way
and starts to apply the inverse force or
even just release the force will see
that the spring energy built up into the
system is enough to peel the adhesive
back off of the substrate and then kind
of retract it back into the into the leg
and this is how they do that they they
have a mechanism by which as they engage
and disengage their feet during a walk
the adhesive automatically is synced
with the motion and so they don't look
like they're tripping because it just
kind of automatically works out so that
that works out great they are slowed by
a little bit by it perhaps but not
enough to notice much and they're able
to do pretty amazing things so that's
ants and they actually use a real sort
of what we think of it as an adhesive a
sticky gooey you know adhesive that
actually leaves a little patch on the
ground well there's an interesting
animal that has some similar properties
but doesn't use quite the same physics
so this is a gecko up here and they are
known as basically the largest animal
that uses adhesion to climb and so they
have a really complicated adhesive
structure so it's bands level so here's
the gecko
he's designed to climb he has fingers
that are designed specifically for
climbing if we zoom in on one of the
little patches here we'd see these rows
of Micro Micro Micro hairs here's one of
these hairs is here and then if we zoom
in even further we see here's a micron
and these are 10 nanometers across so
way smaller than a micron and basically
the idea here is each of these features
is so fine that it conforms to the
surface almost perfectly and so despite
not being actually sticky it's just beta
keratin like your fingernails it's going
to be able to adhere to the surface and
not leave behind any residue which is
convenient so what it does is as it
applies a climbing force the gecko is
going to pull this way and all the hairs
are going to just kind of self a line
onto that surface then it's going to be
stuck to the surface by van der Waals
force and then mechanically as soon as
it remains that force they're all going
to just kind of naturally peel off and
this allows these geckos to actually run
straight up a piece of glass at 15 steps
per second so they're really moving
quickly and that's you know that's
really a fantastic inspiration for us so
we have developed an adhesion adhesive
in our lab that mimics these kind of
behaviors so here's a sem I mean not a
semi an optical microscope view of the
adhesions being loaded onto a piece of
glass that you can't really see in the
shot um you see that the kids make
contact first and then just like the
Gecko as we apply our shear force to
engage onto that surface um we develop
adhesion and that's convenient because
it's going to work like the Gecko in the
direction wanted to go so it's not
wasting any energy it's just pulling
down and unlike tape it's not pressure
sensitive so it's actually shear
sensitive so we pulling shear and it
turns on and remove this year and it
turns off so it's a pretty interesting
material that not many have experienced
yet if we look at its performance we're
going to see that it has directionality
because the adhesives themselves are
directionally have features that go in a
direction so here we have two axes of
stress we have normal stress in this
direction so that's the ability to pull
away from a surface this
below the zero line and then we have
shear stress and that's the ability to
sort of do what friction usually does
for us and so we see that this adhesive
when we pull in shear is able to develop
some pull away force so it locks onto
the surface and as we remove that force
is going to go back to the origin where
it's simply just removed so that's
pretty interesting um here's uh the same
setup and we note that so so the trick
here was we engage in we pull and that
lays over all the features and that's
terrific but the other thing that
happens that we didn't talk about is all
these are little springs and they're all
deformed and so there's energy contained
within all the deformed springs and so
as soon as we let go of that force that
turned on the adhesive now the built-in
spring energy is going to self peel all
of them since there's hundreds and
hundreds of these features on any given
patch um we're able to do peeling all in
parallel and that allows us to remove
this adhesive um very very quickly so
that gives us dynamic performance which
is what that aunt was going to need to
do to run so here we see that the
release time constant was point 01
seconds so pretty fast the other time
constant of interest is how long it has
to settle before it's locked on I'm not
shown here basically at low speeds it's
all fine at ten to the third kpa per
second we see that it starts to get a
little bit upset and so this corresponds
to a reasonably sized robot walking at
about 15 Hertz so pretty quick certainly
fast enough to be useful all right so
thank you for helping me wade through
all those figures now let's do a little
demo can I get a volunteer anyone want
to come up and put us some adhesive all
right I'll do it let me know if you
change your mind oh so here we have our
little adhesive tile so it's the same
video shown there but we have a rigid
tile and on the bottom
we have our adhesive and if I set this
down here on a moderately smooth surface
I can if I just get it happy there we go
I can now pull up to 14 pounds and shoot
for this little object so that's quite a
fair amount but as soon as I pick up
you'll see almost with no force I
couldn't feel that actually it just
comes right off so I'm able to turn it
off and on with a lot of force and then
off again and then on again and I'm able
to do that 15 times a second that's fine
someone ought to try this it's pretty
cool do you want you mind come on up
great so you're going to just pull in
pure shear as you obsess you can like
that and then and you'll see actually as
you pull in pure shear if you do that
again for me it's a little upset on this
table there it goes I can actually pick
up with a little bit of force so I can
hold about ten percent of the weight
that I'm applying and share in the
upward direction as well yeah isn't that
fun and you can see and I'll pass this
around so you can see it if you like but
it's not sticky so here's the material
and it's it's not sticky at all it's
just silicone rubber and to a human
that's what it feels like just rubber
but as soon as you put it on a surface
that it's compatible with it's locked
and so that's a pretty pretty
interesting material one you probably
haven't played with before yet all right
yeah that's a great question another top
basically that was my first project here
at Stanford actually we take a soft wax
substrate right now at least and we take
justice CNC mill and we have a medical
razor blade installed instead of a
turning bit and we carefully trace out
trajectories was sort of maybe five
micron level of accuracy and kind of
press that blade into the wax repeatedly
leaving little cavities that are the
shapes that you saw earlier and then we
cast a liquid silicone rubber on it and
come back in a couple minutes and we
have our sample so it is great for
research that doesn't scale well yet so
that's something to sort of an active
ongoing way to you know crank this out
more than handmade research yeah
boss with the grooves in it when the
mold it's just a soft wax so it's you
can press your finger nail into it and
the wax is sort of low surface energy so
you can remove it later that's one of
the reasons we want it it's also not
very durable and so that's only useful
for one or two times which means that
process doesn't skitzo we're working on
you know the steel mold or something
like that yeah you said the geckos
structure was at the navigator look yes
it is and this is a 100 microns is the
size of the feature the smoothness is
better than that you know it's sort of
micron level smoothness um the trick is
the gecko is actually using beta keratin
like your fingernails and that's really
not sticky you feel that and you know
it's specifically slippery we're using
material because engineering is that a
state where it is we can make these
features we're using silicone which is
more surface energy than beta keratin
and so we can get away with larger
features and still get a similar effect
the downside is that the gecko actually
self Queen's believe it or not if it
gets dirty if it gets dust on it after a
few steps that it's less sticky than the
environment usually is and so it'll come
right off on the trees or the leaves
ours is not sticky to a human and
usually if you find a little bit of sand
in there that sort of fouled it a little
bit if you just touch it will come off
on your fingertips but we're relatively
sticky you know we have oils and things
on us so so it's it's certainly more
sticky than the Gecko and that's an area
of ongoing research you know it'd be
really cool to actually be able to make
the gecko at ease if it's got some
amazing properties but right now that
requires manufacturing on a scale that
we're not capable of quite yet yeah
great question any others more demos got
snorkel stuff alright so we basically
showed a adhesive it's clearly an
adhesive but it has properties kind of
similar to friction if you want to think
of it like that at least functionally
that's sort of a good way to think about
it so that allows us to do relatively
shocking things like this video so this
is my macbook air this one actually and
I can do that and it's not stuck at all
I can pick it up and put it down but I
can handle maybe 85 degrees to vertical
and it's it's fine you can see the top
actually starts to tilt away because the
moment induced you know if you do the
static
but it's able to do that so that's a
pretty interesting capability if you're
prone to dropping laptops which I am and
I've actually been using that exact
setup for the last year and it's still
on my laptop same adhesive is original I
can't really move it up from the way
here but I can show you it's a macbook
air so it weighs about two pounds so you
know rubber you'd expect about two
pounds of force it's enough that it's I
can move myself and then I can still
simply pick it up and it's it's not even
a hindrance we have another demo video
using bigger feet on the bottom that I'm
able to pull myself to the desk like
this using only a macbook air so pretty
interesting properties you've probably
not encountered in normal life very
often so so we've sort of talked about
this material as an adhesive that's
functionally more like friction well
that allows us to do something even more
surprising so if we put it as a thin
film like a tape I can lift up an object
with no effort and then I can under its
own weight simply drop the tape back off
and that's really strange so please
someone come up and try this I brought a
demo so maybe even a couple people yeah
great come on all right so this takes a
little bit of touch but so this is made
to go in this direction on this football
and that should work out pretty well so
go ahead and pick it up you got it this
gripper was designed for that geometry
we can make more versatile ones but this
is a simple demo that's relatively yeah
they're actually the two different
directions are opposed so they tend to
bite the surface like that so same
material is the other one it is it's
just sort of Oregon film now yeah bigger
um that's we don't need quite this size
but it makes it bulletproof for a demo
you know I'm not actually watching this
is my PhD thesis and I'm not even
worried about it so that says that it
actually works pretty well so another
cool trick you can do with it so just
plop it on there and you can actually
simply blow it off and comes right up so
please someone else it's cool you got to
try it okay give it a shot
we've talked to we've talked about that
turns out they actually use an active
adhesive if you watch they don't touch
the ground because their fingers are
actually sticky so they're pretty
cautious about that so this is less
sticky than they use but there's no
reason we can't make a formulation
that's more sticky normally and then
behaves more like less sticky under some
conditions so certainly an area of
interest yet another question ok what's
the manufacturing cost of those know now
is hanging with my PhD students so
terrible we'll be free soon as I
graduate though that a costume uh yeah
it's it's just silicone rubber and it's
yeah since since yeah silicon is more
expensive than other plastics but still
we're talking sense not dollars who
listens yeah I mean if your world a role
and it's just sort of turning this out
they won't cost much at all yes the CNC
mill process we can do this way can you
change it your dump a bowl picture over
some control in there are systems that
do that um they often have other
compromises so I think your ideal would
eventually be hi everybody haven't
figured out quite how to negotiate the
apps and downs basically to get more
switching losses in performance yet
exactly exactly that makes sense yep um
yeah another one of interest is a slight
flow outward to just kind of get a
little bit of back to my surface that
can help teens abomino flow turbo
viscous yeah I don't know how something
so you know they said I wrong that's
actually they like to see system not yet
maybe later so that was all interesting
stuff um and I hope the demo is going
around and you're enjoying it yeah you
got it there we go all right yeah that's
pretty much the Gordon the kids respond
differently than adults these are
actually yeah it's interesting
you know we've given this demo a lot of
times and the children actually do
better because they're more okay with
physics that don't make sense a lot of
the adults know they have the right to
vote them forever yeah I'm thinking that
something comfortable to a tank crib a
loop of this that with tangled on
something we'll be able to pull it quite
a bit and then release as the geometry
brought something for certain and that
can happen yeah so you can almost pick
up a ball and cause the ball to spin as
a dangle from this tractor credit you
certainly might be able to UM one of the
tricks with the tractor tread is getting
so we have almost no away force right
it's basically all share um and so the
tractor tread sometimes doesn't want to
stay on the surface because there's no
incentive to do so so it certainly can
work but getting those forces out or
tricky I think the best idea I've had is
suction along that surface with a flat
substrate or something to kind of keep
it down so there's certainly things one
can do but it's it's a little
unintuitive you've got to play with it a
little bit um that the tile that I
showed you is actually one of the
easiest low-hanging fruits to get a lot
out of it but clearly that film is
bizarre and we're still getting our
heads around exactly what to do with it
forces the sticky tape the office to you
look at the microstates I cute microwar
to Ziggy oh really yeah interesting with
my don't know that that's fun very cool
very cool this your season alright got
it I already have my thesis so I'm good
and have another student I just need to
turn in stone it's actually worse
because that makes more to season in
your wick pead oh you actually produce
sex rings yeah take down man I knew my
x-rays to the x-ray Finn uh-huh take
down a message and then it was exposed
that's how I figure out why was it
exposed that's cold so I was like a
mortise and that's really two sausage
basic very viscous actually a trifle
scream disgusted thanks Evan what you
see that's very cool umm so so learning
we have a material here this is a simple
demo to getting your head
that was the point you know it's pretty
sparse there's a thread and a stick and
a piece of tape and that's about it well
what happens if we try to build this
material level intelligence into a more
complicated system so here is a fairly
more complicated system so here we have
a series of these tapes and some air
bags behind them basically and this is
all compressed with a spring only so
this is you can see that poof ball do
that one more time I demonstrates how
much force this is it's basically
nothing just enough to kind of engage
them on the surface that's a very
squishy objects that should be deforming
if there's any force and it's not serve
out at all it's set by a spring at some
point in the system and that's all that
we get and we can see that this probably
two-dollar robotic hand I mean a robot
in quotes there's nothing fancy here at
all is able to pick up a huge variety of
objects I'm with almost no intelligence
so sacks of things potato chips bigger
objects so yeah we've certainly done
some of that we have quad copters
actually that can perch on walls and
ceilings and you know release is the
important part you can always put duct
tape on a quadcopter and stick to them
but releasing is the hard part so really
interesting material with some clearly
interesting properties well that's a
given no well we don't need that various
ways to get Sigma 3 breaking sure
including just remove the magnetic
fields is surely to do sure but that
vessel is but it could be an active kid
magnetic yeah usually we just remove the
weight which is an asymmetry break as
well and that's enough to do that and if
you are able to get on a ceiling you're
probably able to move your weight that's
sort of it comes with the territory
usually so yeah this is really
interesting I think yeah this is a cool
shot so this is a box for picking up
that's that's easy of course but we're
going to do it the hard way which is
actually hard for a human
that works fine so basically in the end
of the day here we have demonstrated an
adhesive that you can think of like
friction with the coefficient of
friction and most reasonable situations
of like hundreds so a pretty bizarre
thing that we're not used to dealing
with very much great so it is strong
like a standard adhesive and it is fast
and controllable like friction but this
is going to have a cost everything has a
cost so that's not a huge surprise um if
we look at the wedges we're in this
state before we apply a force we apply a
force we get a displacement that means
work so in the loaded state we've added
work to the system now as a human it's
not enough work to notice you know as
you're playing with that football you
didn't notice that it was deforming just
a little bit it doesn't matter but if we
start to become aunt scale all of a
sudden that work is going to start to
add up um and so that's going to be
something that'll be a core thing we're
going to have to deal with in micro
robots all right any other questions
before we move on from adhesive they'll
be more of it but but yeah and we can
talk more after um it's van der Waals
force is that what you mean yeah no that
was pretty clear so now we're going to
build a series of robots that
demonstrate the various unique
properties of this adhesive so let's say
I wanted to make a small object that
influences the world as an engineer I
need engineering ideas maybe not in
nature idea is quite so much sometimes
so I'm using a tugboat as an inspiration
here as an engineer we have a tugboat
consists of fuel a lot of it a giant
engine and a giant propeller and then
the humans up here are just basically
accessories so not much else just engine
propeller and fuel
alright um so let's make a robot
equivalent of this tugboat we're going
to see that we have a lot of fuel or in
this case a lipo so it's about thirty
percent of the volume up there we're
going to have the engine becomes
incredibly important if we want a small
robot that can exert a large force
there's two problems one is the ground
reaction force and that's the equivalent
to propeller and that's a problem but we
have the cities of this cool and now the
engineering challenge is just getting
enough actuator in this volume to
accomplish the necessary goal and so
that'll be a large actuator so we're
going to use these robots to demonstrate
for different properties of the
adhesives specifically the speed full
use of the adhesive force the efficiency
of a system using these adhesives in
this way and then the light touch of
engagement we're able to see you when I
was using the football I could just
throw it on there and not press it down
and that's a pretty handy feature
alright so this is a force displacement
curve so for those of you who aren't
physicist or mechanical engineers we
have displacement in this direction and
we have the force required to get there
basically pressure but same thing and if
we integrate anything in this curve we
will see joules per meter squared so
basically it's the work that the system
has to do to achieve these points so as
discussed the adhesives at zero force
are under zero displacement that says
expected and then as we increase the
force little by little we're going to
increase the displacement out to here
for the adhesives be performing at peak
capability we're seeing about seven
joules per meter squared and this star
point here so that's a really important
point in order to use this system at its
best you ought to be operating at the
star point or not further because you'll
fail but the star point is the goal hmm
so microrobots have one unique and
tricky challenge and that's actuators
there are not many great actuators once
you get small enough motors start to
peter out at about this sort of one inch
size scale and then we're left with
solid-state actuators which are
fantastic for some applications so we
have kaizo electrics electroactive
polymers shape-memory alloy wire all
pretty useful materials in a lot of
applications I'm but we'll see
the psycho work for piezo electrics
they're very fast the power is
reasonable but the work per stroke is
quite miniscule so if we were to use pzt
for our only actuator to develop this
only this amount of effort you know the
peak work we're talking about 4 1 cubic
inch robot we would be taking over fifty
percent of our total volume with simply
the bulk pzt no transmission no battery
no power supply nothing else it's just
half pzt and that is completely
unacceptable to make this actually
happen um electroactive polymers are
going to be better they have factor of
twenty more work per cycle so that's
great that means they're down to two
point four percent which is totally
reasonable for an engineer however they
also require one killable power supply
which is again unreasonable um so
there's all these challenges with
dealing with these solid-state adhesives
um we will note that years if you can
get them small enough don't have a work
cycle they keep rotating forever and
that makes them ideal if you're able to
use them and so we're going to use some
of that sometimes but will also
demonstrate use with the more hard to
use materials as well to show that it's
possible so looking at that now we're
going to talk about adhesive speed so
the first two in that table were pzt and
electroactive polymers and this is their
force displacement curve as actuators um
there's a variety of reasons it's a
different shape this is sort of typical
in this kind of actuator and so to
achieve this point we need to have that
on this line and that means that our
actuators are going to have to to do
this slope to achieve that point that's
just some basic geometry um because this
is their slope and not matching what we
actually wanted that means we're going
to waste four times the work cycle that
was already hard to do because this poor
shape match and that's problematic um so
that means that they're going to be
requiring 28 joules per meter squared
instead of seven much worse however they
are very fast and that's where we're
going to use them to demonstrate the
adhesive speed so we have built this
very simple simple simple robot it's
almost comical how simple it is and
therefore it's hard to understand as
always so here we have a schematic
showing how it works it's basically for
legs moving with two bending elements so
I have the function of this is basically
that I'm going to flop on the ground
kind of like a fish I'm just going to do
this over and over and i'll raise up my
belly and then drop down and raise up my
arms and then keep cycling through and
with pzt you don't get much displacement
so you won't get to see that very well
but if you look carefully you can and
i'll show you where to look so here is
our actual little robot we have a dummy
proof mass because it was easier to run
power off board for now but we have
these two bending actuators and then the
adhesive feet and then the payload which
is about 10 body weights which is not
incredible yet but it's certainly more
than nothing the adhesives have about 2
centimeters squared so we'll need about
point zero zero five joules this system
is able to develop about a twentieth of
that so this is really not demonstrating
the force yet it's just showing that
they are they are capable of being fast
um so without further ado here is our
first micro tug robot so you see the
motion there if you look carefully this
is operating at sixteen hurts now and at
16 hurts is fast enough it just kind of
seems like it's gliding um and there
I'll do that one more time so you can
just now that you know what you're
looking at there's a little walk there's
the faster walk and here's the the glide
talking about ten body weights um that's
interesting question because it depends
on the amount of load the more I loaded
the deeper into that cycle I get the
more stuck I am with light loads so the
five grams of its body weight I was able
to run easily at 64 hurts for pulling 10
body weights behind it I had to slow it
down 16 was a um complicated yeah a
minimum of the speed a minimum time we
didn't check very carefully all the
different parameters the adhesive itself
is pretty nonlinear because you're
getting increasing patches as you
displace it's monotonic yes but it's
it's not just a simple quadratic or line
for sure so
my head I'm not sure I can sort of
carefully think about that but it not
while I'm giving a live talk um all
right thanks I'm almost done yeah wheels
are greased and move easier hey
certainly wedge so this is steel on
glass and and you bring up a very good
point that the research topic is
dragging let's be clear about that and
dragging is always confounded by
friction so just get that out there it's
absolutely true we tried not to cheat
very much you know steel on glass is a
relatively common thing i'm not using
teflon or not using grease steel on
glass was this and that's the
performance but it certainly is very
much true we're not trying to over claim
we're trying to say that in a realistic
scenario this is what it can do later we
will over claim a little bit but try not
to overplay too much yeah yeah I mean
it's just inherently true that it's
always going to depend on friction this
topic it doesn't mean that you can't
still appreciate as a human that if I
did that that would be hard but there's
always going to be that confounding
variable that's friction you know a lot
of the comments I get is you know we'll
just float it on a boat and you can do
infinite weight like well yeah but
that's not useful anyway so here is
again demonstrating speed with piezo
electric actuators they've got a ways to
go before they can get the work out of
the system but we can handle the speed
when they get there so that's that's
great this is pretty bad I wasn't trying
to optimize for efficiency at all so
physics yeah PCT is pretty efficient
it's probably eighty percent overall um
the problem is and we'll get to that
actually in the third section so there's
there's an important part to make about
efficiency in such a system so what
we'll get to that but yeah it's not very
efficient as is the actuator itself is
pretty good but the system is wasting a
lot of power you don't understand
physics well I understand some of the
physics but the pzt yeah okay it's
tricky the PCT is not very capable and
we have to push it to its limits to get
it to work at all okay so how
talks about pzt which didn't have a ton
of work we're going to now look at
something that has more work available
and so we're going to be able to
actually use the full force the
adhesives so here we are as a reminder
here's a controllable adhesive work
here's the point we need to achieve here
is the pzt and electroactive polymer
curves so poor shape match factor for
more than we needed now shape-memory
alloys an interesting material because
it's got a curve that's basically flat
and so that's really interesting it's
clearly a better shape match for we're
trying to achieve and so a shape-memory
alloy we only need 14 joules per meter
squared which is much better but even
more importantly shape-memory alloy in
addition has an extra 200 times the work
per volume of pzt so all of a sudden now
we're talking this is a functional
system again there's also a 2 X less
work required so we're talking four
hundred times better than the pzt robots
and this is going to be enough work to
fully really use the adhesives which is
fantastic so here is our robot schematic
this is what you'll see in a video in a
second basically we have two feet an
outer foot and an inner foot and they
have a spring in between them and then a
tail is attached to two pieces of SMA
wire the wires going to contract when it
gets hot and pull the one foot with
respect to the other and the result is
an inchworm gate that kind of just moves
like that so the main portion the
functional portion here is about 4 grams
assembled with batteries and everything
else it's about 12 and it's functional
we actually pulled our most famous lab
member sticky part up a while with this
object but the efficiency was just
absolutely beyond terrible it was so bad
it's ridiculous so we don't do much with
it but here it is in use this is just
the body so this is about 4 grams and if
I hit play we're going to see this for
gram robot moving a 2.5 kilogram steel
on blast load there's this little
inchworm gate there we're moving the
load so that's you know that's certainly
getting interesting all of a sudden now
you're just showing off I'm not yet
this polite one of one more than the
other I be like walking so there's some
complicated asymmetric the writer from
battle that's part of the question
deliah the course of all seem to be
really more work them that's true it's
accidental it's hard to build these are
my hand but ideally wanted symmetrical
if you're not turning yeah yeah that
would be the goal so you said walking
call it it's taking its full front and
putting it down and then it's full back
so it's yeah it's supposed to be
symmetric and then a very humanity Louis
versus a decent yeah we're saving mine
certainly or even circular like no but
might have different efficiencies they
certainly would and that would allow you
to do things like turn left and right
for this example we're really only
focused on Canha micro robot pull a
large thing and the answer here is yes
signatures of the physics yes interested
to remodel yeah it's an inchworm that's
right um listen complexities because
these are all tenants driving it's
there's a lot of we could talk about
later but but it's enough summit of
forgotten that's been a while if it is a
complicated thing to make it work it
certainly works and it relies on the
properties of the use to kind of get
some of those things to work alright so
that's that's neat now let's talk about
actual efficiency and this is sort of
where we're going to see some problems
so uh ok so again we have our adhesive
required work to turn on we have our pzt
curve up here and remember the pzt was
hard to do so we're not really even
achieving this point probably we're a
little bit down below it but that would
be ideal and then we have SMA well this
was the work required to turn on the
adhesives and at that point we've
actually accomplished nothing the
adhesives is on and that's it we haven't
done any external work so in that case
our efficiency is zero it did turn on
the adhesives which is helpful but the
efficiency still hasn't come into play
it's at zero so this is very interesting
because if we extend SMA out a little
bit that's more realistic of what you'd
have to do you have to get something
after you've achieved that point and we
see now aha motors are able to just
continually cycle and so now all of a
sudden we can get efficiency added
system
and that's very helpful so if we used
SMA again as noted if we only stopped
here we've achieved an efficiency of
zero in that cycle if we go out to 125
microns instead of 100 now we're up to
thirty three percent even at 200 microns
we are only in point 66 still so you
know it takes a while to accumulate
functional work out of this system so
really we want the actuator be as long
as possible and again a motor is going
to allow us to do that so here is our
motor based micro tug um we are loading
the adhesives and any other springs in
each cycle represents a fixed loss so if
I have an extra spring that's a more
loss but we know at least the adhesives
will be a loss at infinite step size the
efficiency that doesn't matter anymore
because now we're just limited by our
actuators work efficiency to put at work
and winches allow for near arbitrary
step size independent of the robot so I
can make the one cubic inch robot that
has a winch that pulls 46 inches and
that would be sort of ridiculous if that
was its actual walking distance that
doesn't work so winches are incredibly
attractive from an efficiency standpoint
small DC motors have efficiency on the
order of ten to twenty percent
interestingly they're limited by their
bearings usually the torque output of
the motor as you get that small becomes
diminishing Lee small small enough that
the sort tiny little jewel bearings
they're using the high-end ones become a
fixed percentage of that torque that's a
lot of it and so you start to this
efficiency so very weak and of friction
is goats 20 it's like a superconducting
effect interesting to look at yeah
that's interesting places was watching
to statistical a bit interesting that's
good um anyway so we're seeing about
twenty percent efficiency um the
shape-memory alloy from the previous
robot was able to achieve the work which
is great but it's sort of theoretical
max for most alloys is on the order of
two percent and in our practical
application where we're using it poorly
in a micro robot without much control
we're way lower than that factors of 10
at least so this means that our
batteries can be dramatically smaller
and as we saw the batteries are a
non-negligible part of the volume and so
that's going to be incredibly helpful
so here is an explosion view of the
actual robot so at the bottom we've got
our tile as we all saw and it has
tendons sort of running around it as a
pulley going back to a hook and then a
little outlet here and then that string
is attached to the output of a winch
it's a micro servo basically that's been
hacked on the output shaft there we also
attach this series of motors and wheels
that is able to lift and lower as the
the clutch move so it's just a friction
clutch between here and the winch and
spool there represents a loss because
you always have friction moving there
but it is able to get a lot of degrees
of freedom for cubic inch which is hard
then we have a sensor to sense how far
the winch has been moving because a lot
of these systems are going to be close
to stalled and so the time can be poor
measure of what you're doing and then we
have processor motor drivers and
batteries on top and putting that all
together we have our first really
functional engineering device so here is
little 12 gram robot you can drive
forward turn and then raise and lower
his belly and you'll see that the
adhesives on the bottom aren't even
slowing it down yeah he's able to go
quite fast but then when he wants he can
lower his belly on the ground and now
winch that coffee cup all over the place
he's got that coffee cup like crazy
coffee cup was about 50 body weights if
i'm not mistaken useful here's a
comparable weight n sized robot clearly
not accomplishing much because its
restriction but here's 350 body weights
this is nine pounds I gave up finding
weights in lab clearly there is able to
to do his little gate so it makes sense
any questions good time for now we're
going to test the the limits of
engineering here on the adhesive can do
about twice this this is about 50 pounds
so about 2,000 body weights or so um and
the main limit is actually the motor the
adhesives are fine to do more but the
motor wants to explode so we yeah so so
that's about what we can achieve without
sort of stepping up and we do step up
later but there is just very hard to get
a combination of drivers and actually
years together in a cubic inch if you
give yourself a little more space than
absolutely but we kind of had there's a
classification of robot called nano
sumos you could but there's no
commercial ones available and the
research isn't make things but yeah it
is that's right yeah thank goodness
you're doing this for us where you're on
the inch system because accused so
believe it or not the standard actually
I think came from Japan I don't know why
but they have these nano Zoomer robots
that have fights and the goal is to push
each other around and so the joke is
we've won that competition we didn't
actually I don't want to enter but but
you certainly could do quite well ok so
I got to move forward a little bit yeah
that's right um so we have robot
efficiency here so we see as the step
size increases the efficiency goes up as
expected however our corner position
here basically is on the order of
millimeters so this is dominated by
extra springs in the system that are
unaccounted for by the adhesives it's
the same effect it's all going to be the
same effect and that tells you that if
you make your system stiffer you'll get
better efficiency for a stroke or if you
increase your step size to be ridiculous
than none of that matters anyway it's
still lost but it doesn't really
functionally matter um great here's the
ground reaction forces we measure red is
sheer clearly we have a ton of sheer
capabilities um interestingly blue is
the normal force so here we see the
robot driving on to the platform and
here's his weight difference from the
start there so that's the robot way and
then during the pole cycle he actually
develops 50 body weights away from the
surface because it really isn't adhesion
we're thinking about by friction but it
is an adhesive so he's developing 50
body weights upwards while doing this
sort of ridiculous maneuver here so
that's pretty exciting there's a lot
more videos but I've got to actually
move along we're running out of time and
okay so so there's lots on our YouTube
channel you can find them all that was
for the BBC kids show so there was a
little bit more less formal it's cute um
so now why types of engagement I'm going
to kind of fly to this but the trick is
that it doesn't require much pressing
you know some tapes you really want to
push down and mash
down but if you're climbing that's going
to be hard because if I have to press
down with my upper hand that means I'm
pushing my body away with the lower hand
and that's problematic so we've built a
little robot to demonstrate climbing
here's a measurement of the almost zero
force of engagement compared to the
loads that it's able to take when it
actually takes the step and I'll show
you a little video of it climbing so
this is 110 body weights payload so 5
pounds or something like that and that's
how it takes this little step and you
see that it doesn't require any push in
force at all it's just skittering on the
surface barely to turn on but as soon as
the shear happens now it's locked so
that's a cute little robot the table
decline with a hundred body weight
payload that's neat so um yeah yep yeah
we can actually yes it was certainly 90
degrees I think we had one that did a
little bit more just for fun that's a
little bit harder um so anyways here
we've shown that the adhesive has speed
it has a work of engagement it has a
step efficiency and a light touch of
engagements these are all the properties
you need to consider when using these
for microrobots careful consideration of
these properties and actuator selections
allows you to make a robot that's able
to move a 50-pound weight on glass and
that's pretty surprising so if we look
where this stands compared to existing
state of the art which of course they
weren't trying to pull things so but
this is just sort of as a comparison we
have Micro robots that are frictional
and don't have much weight are here so
length and weight are correlated
basically um this is what you kind of
expect if you were just predicting an
average weight climbing robots do a bit
better because they always are adhesive
they have to be to climb that sort of
comes with the territory but they're
they're right here um here's our micro
tug body weight so if it had a
coefficient of 1 frictional material
that would be the red dashed line and we
see if we add our micro tug to this
curve wait for it there so we're clearly
a bit of an outlier and this is able to
actually affect the human scale world so
that's pretty exciting speaking of
climbing because
the smells credit socials yeah yeah I
know you're 17 that's right smooth
materials that work on that see who the
head that's right Brandon all right so
we've got not a ton of time so I'm going
to try to get through these last couple
slides so so now the question is we've
developed robots that are individually
able to have a lot of force and you
recall the other way we did that
engineering-wise was the impulse which
was sort of problematic so we're going
to go through exactly why that is but
now that we have more ant-like things
can they actually share load like ants
so this is a picture of I don't know
maybe eight ants moving an object that's
not huge but they're clearly working
together to do it which is great and now
for the cool thing this is a video that
stuffing the graph de greef allowed me
to use so here we have isn't this
incredible this this millipede actually
goes out like here it's huge and we
actually see teams of robots I mean
teams of ants sorry locking on to each
other to apply load sharing to the
system when the perimeter runs out there
all along the perimeter that's a granted
but once the parameter runs out there
actually biting onto each other and
sharing load this is incredible
capability from these dances really neat
so the question is can we use teams of
microbots to do the same thing so now
instead of one robot we have n what
would we get if we did these impulsive
ones what we saw before well um one
impulsive robot has a peak force about
15 grams 20 impulsive robots has a peak
force about 30 grams so they're
basically not doing anything together at
all it moves faster because we've added
more power to the system but they're not
any extra capability really at all again
that's just because if you look at the
sparse curve from one and you put
another random one on top of it they
never add just like that clapping never
really added if you had really good
synchronization they could write they
can't and then it's just hard and we
actually tried that we seismically
excited the whole system so that that
should be pretty consistent and it turns
out that these robots are so impulsive
the error that causes a complete
mismatch of those signals is only 500
microns Dickinson I
and given that their toys they never
were able to synchronize that well and
believe it or not in such a system it
made it worse because it introduces
system Eric no carriers instead of just
random ones so certainly that's possible
if you can do it and it's just an
engineering challenge but it would
require a minimum good communication and
hopefully knowledge of the environment
too because these impulses happen short
time as well as short displacements you
need to know exactly when you're going
to hit two existing Kragh nice very well
as a story muggles have been able to get
the kids from underneath the car lifting
a call enough by really focusing yeah
yeah I know never get into that story
about this clearly done alright so this
is I really have to fly because we're
basically out of time um but this is a
statistical model it's just a binomial
distribution with some modifications to
make it work for this particular
scenario the basic that we're saying
that if your contact pouches are wider
you're more likely to add and if they're
narrower there'll be more force
individually but they won't add as well
so here we see a cute little video of
twenty robots being wrangled on my desk
and they basically don't accomplish much
so here is the force per robot as we
increase the number of robots it just
basically plateaus doesn't do anything
useful and here's the actual slope so in
some cases if you do it well you're
getting three times or something I can't
quite tell from this angle the force out
of 20 robots it's still quite poor how
would you improve this you're going to
improve the time in which they're
generating the force is it better with
synchronization it's a great question it
can be so here's synchronization you're
just going to sort of effectively reduce
the stroke length mathematically but the
problem is that has the possibility for
systematic error like this and can cause
worse problems it sort of just depends
how good your synchronization is in how
specific the case is interestingly we
can actually take walking robots and
convert them into running robots by
driving more power into them
functionally and we actually see that if
you're trying to do one robot you're
better running because you're going to
have some of these surge effects
the walking ones right there but even
after five robots the walking ones
actually start to exceed the
capabilities of the the running one so
this is a very real effect that happens
so how would we achieve ideal load
sharing well we'd make it all green
basically what have we showed before
very slow robots that are operating over
a long time in a long distance so this
is going to be totally perfect for our
micro tuck robots here's their effective
gate it's just very boring it's flat and
in fact if we take six robots we get
linearly six times the force allowing us
to not lose anything so this is maybe
the assumed results if you weren't
thinking very carefully of this system
but it's basically as good as you're
going to get and that allows this team
of six to do I think about 84 pounds of
peak force which is interesting because
our lightest lab mate who was on the
paper can only apply about 87 pounds of
force so we almost beat one of our
authors here's a test showing that not
super important here is one of the new
version of the winching robots so better
gearbox differ more efficient all those
things we talked about wanting on
there's a 50 pound weight now it's able
to easily pull out the other one is
struggling here's seven them kind of
being tested at the same time and then
we take six of those the best ones
because one broke and here is six of
them at 20 times speed pulling my actual
daily commute vehicle so now we are
cheating a bit we're using a car but
clearly this is a force large enough the
children couldn't do it and that's the
goal it's just give something people
humans understand you know something
that they might have seen but know that
it's difficult and so there we are
pulling a car so again if we look at the
micro robots from friction based and
climbing and then we add one micro
targets there and now we've scaled
without any loss which is always hard to
do in the real world and so if we look
at that team as a single robot with some
modifications mathematically it would
show up about their which is now clearly
getting a bit ridiculous and so we have
truly shown ant-like capabilities we're
affecting the human scale world with
small robots and that's pretty exciting
I won't go much into the takeaways
takeaways what you saw it's pretty neat
here I think
there's a great video you should watch
on our youtube channel narrated lovely
and stuff a little more for human
consumption than a research talk so the
last point to make here is ok so we've
shown swarms actually working now we
have seven robots mechanically working
together that's great so can we use this
to do things in the real world how about
building big structures well ants if we
look at our example again are able to
build gigantic structures they're
incredibly cool so that's clearly
possible for ants however the thing to
note is that basically ants are building
incredibly complicated but not specific
structures and that's a difference so
for swarm mechanics it's a lot easier to
say here's your motivations just figure
it out but as engineers in the human
world we almost always want specific
things and that makes swarm research
tricky so we have a paper about this
recently that's just pointing out that
it's tricky no solutions yet but
basically the idea is with a specific
structure we're almost always implying a
top-down result and integrating that
into swarm mechanics becomes problematic
more research is necessary and it's
exciting to see when it figures out but
it's not obvious exactly the ways to
make those work all right thank you for
coming to the talk thank you to the
co-authors and thank you everyone
they were at their maximum rated level
yes pharma tires it was entombed up the
50 yeah I it was whatever these tires
are specifically I don't remem oh you
have the same power okay so 50 yes I
think you read 50 50 got it this is a
wonderful engineering huh yeah yes great
comic he said well when you we want the
plows through you want to straw dogs and
horses 24 chickens unfortunately he died
that's a good kind red nose you know
2,000 bunny rabbits which is not an
impulsive yeah but when you can't make
oxen big enough what did you sell my
stuff also hard to synchronize so we
actually have a room besides robot to
that I didn't talk about that can move
200 pounds each year so enough to move
about 2,000 pounds on a smooth surface
without cheating pretty much anything
that your Dillon football there is the
fact that a quarter of it is not a
smooth surface little white side yes
it's not effective on this was designed
specifically for that we can do the
other but both is hard at this point
insurance that's right
you